[cheers and applause]
[funk music]
♪ ♪
- ♪ GOT A POCKET FULL OF FUNKY
WITH A PEPPERMINT TWIST ♪
♪ SHE'S A COOL, SHIFTY MAMA
BLASTIN' OFF ON THE FLIP ♪
- ♪ IRIDESCENT PORK BELLY
GALACTIC SUPER TRAIN ♪
♪ MAMA SISTER PLAYGROUND
WITH A STRAW DADDY CANE ♪
♪ UH-HUH ♪
♪ ♪
- ♪ GOTTA GET IT UP ♪
- ♪ HEY ♪
- ♪ GOTTA GET IT ON ♪
- ♪ UH ♪
- ♪ GOTTA GET IT DOWN ♪
- ♪ HEY ♪
- ♪ GOTTA MAKE IT STRONG ♪
- ♪ GOT THAT QUICK DIP CRAYON
EARTHQUAKE JET PACK ON A BUN ♪
♪ LOCOMOTIVE SUPERNOVA
SPANISH HARLEM SUN ♪
- ♪ YEAH ♪
- ♪ SLICK CRAWFISH SOLAR BLAST
WITH A PHOSPHORESCENT BRAIN ♪
- ♪ WHO'S THAT MAMA SQUAT TOWN?
DEEP FRIED DETROIT SODA TRAIN ♪
- ♪ GOTTA SHAKE IT UP ♪
♪ GOTTA MOVE IT IN ♪
♪ GOTTA PUT IT DOWN ♪
- ♪ YOU GOTTA MAKE IT SWIM ♪
- ♪ NEBULATIC COMETS
SANITATION DISEASE ♪
- ♪ QUICK PLAY TORNADO
RIP AND TICKLE BEEF SNEEZE ♪
- ♪ HEY ♪
- ♪ SHIPS PLANETS JUSTICE
CANNONS, CABLES, AND TREES ♪
- ♪ DOCTOR'S OFFICE PENGUIN
SHILLINGS, RAILROADS, AND PEAS ♪
- ♪ I SAID CRIPPLED DONKEY
MEL BROOKS BOOK TRAIN ♪
♪ BATS ON MY KNEES ♪
- ♪ PENICILLIN TRAPDOOR
LASER CURRENCY BEANS ♪
- ♪ HE SAY PENICILLIN TRAPDOOR
- HEY, WHAT THE HELL
ARE WE SAYING, MAN?
- I GOT NO IDEA, MAN.
I'M JUST HUNGRY
AND TALKING
ABOUT THE GALAXY AND TRASH.
I THINK THEY BUYING IT,
THOUGH.
[song ends]
[cheers and applause]